- Look at this.
- But look at Apollo.
- Look at Apollo though.
- You can see the air between the shot
and the head popping, bro.
- Nah.
(cheering music)
- What's up everybody, my
name is Michael Hughes.
I'm a trainer at Church Street boxing gym.
2012 NY Golden Gloves Champion.
- Yeah. What's up
everybody? I'm Kenny Ocean.
I'm also a trainer here at
Church Street Boxing Gym.
I'm a NY Boxing Tournament winner, 2017.
- Today we're going to be
critiquing Hollywood boxing films.
- You know, we're exposin'
real from the fake.
That's what we here to do.
We got our first film "Ali".
One of my favorite boxing movies.
- Very dramatic fight
scene. Ali on the ropes.
- Will Smith taking a lot of blows.
But it look like he
really takin' the blows.
- Doin' pretty good. Ali mimic movements.
- Poppin that jab, moving.
- He's letting them fly a little bit.
- Oooooh.
- That's not bad. It's
a pretty good combo.
- Nah, you can't tell me
you didn't like this movie.
- It's alright. It's alright.
It was good. It was good.
- Look at his face. (laughing)
- Tad bit. That was good movement by Will.
I like the little fake movements he did.
- But overall, I would
really say the movement
is like, is just alike. You know?
That was kinda old.
- That was a little over dramatic.
- Yeah that was a little over dramatic
the way he slip punched.
But, look at the feet.
- I like the action shots.
- Yeah.
- Will Smith, you can tell he definitely
studied his Ali footage.
- Yeah.
- He mimicked the Ali jab pretty well.
- Sometimes they just do it
a little bit too dramatic.
Where a person's getting
their offense off,
and the other person is just like,
too much of like, it's like a heavy bag.
Overall that wasn't too bad.
Will Smith did his homework.
I like that.
- He did his thing, he did his thing
- Alright, next up we got one of the
boxing classics, Raging Bull.
- (chuckling) I swear to God.
- He's mimicking Lamar's movement's
pretty well with the lean in.
Alright, the one thing
with this off the rip,
it's just too much of
a dramatic fight scene
where he's lettin off
three, four, five shots
and he's just getting ripped.
It's just too easy, look at that.
- Too easy. If that was
the real Ray Robinson
he woulda clipped him.
(chuckling) I don't know.
- And you can kinda
see some of the punches
when they're throwin and
you can see the head turnin.
It's not like a clean fake hit.
- I get a little bit like that,
you know, when I knock somebody down.
You know, you get that
little puff in your chest.
- Robinson was getting hit way to easily.
Lamato was throwing like
a four, five, six, like,
left, right combo at Robinson
and Robinson's head
was just bobble heading
with no defense. That's not realistic.
- I feel like Ray Robinson coulda been
portrayed better a little bit.
- Yeah, definitely.
Robert De Niro though mimicked
Jack Lamato really well.
Raging Bull style, coming
forward with the pressure.
Next up, "Million Dollar
Baby", another classic.
Hillary Swank is moving on her feet.
She's carrying pretty well.
- Oh. She got hit with the jab.
- That pop. She would get
tagged, her head would pop.
Which is kinda realistic,
if you're backing up
and you get hit end of the
punch, your head can snap back.
The footwork isn't too
bad. That right there.
- Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
- Yeah, that looked choreographed.
That looked choreographed.
(chuckles) That was slow motion.
- Oh nah. (laughing) She's wailing.
- So it started off pretty okay.
And she caught it with
these two bombing hooks.
- She really took down her hands and got
ready for the punch.
- Yeah she just went from
like covering full guard
to then just getting hit openly.
- Was like, yes this is the scene,
I'm gonna get knocked out.
- Overall this film is great though.
- So right now we looking at Creed.
You know, Michael B.
Jordan aka Killmonger,
Wakanda forever. Always.
With this he like he's squaring up
for a street fight.
Oh that was kinda fake.
Okay. (laughs)
Okay. Unless he's psychic.
(laughter)
That was fake.
- Yeah, yeah yeah. He anticipated that
a little bit too well.
You can tell that they prepared by
doing some like, legit pad work for this,
but then it looks like they're doing
pad work in the fight scene.
- Oooooh, that kinda looked good.
Oooooh.
- I don't even believe that because
- You don't?
- He's standing super far away and he just
rips him with the over
hand right with no set up.
You can tell that they try to make it more
realistic but at the same time,
to me it looked like boxing pad work.
Pad work is when you have your trainer
holding pads, calling out combinations,
you can see like a clear
combo where it's like
slip, slip, roll, hook, hook, cross, roll,
6, 3, come in like one
more thing with Creed,
where he gets dropped,
and the ref is counting
"1, 2," and he gets up like "7, 8, 9",
and he just like springs.
He's like unconscious. In real life,
you're not gonna go from...to popping up.
Never in life would you
ever see that happen.
- This is Rocky.
I love this. Mike said he hate it.
I don't know why.
(Mike laughs)
- We gon' click and see
what fight scene this is.
- Hold up, hold up, hold up
- What?
- For the record, I don't hate it.
- Aaah.
- The boxing.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- I got static, that's
code terms for problems
with the boxing.
- Apollo Creed gettin'
that little swag on, oooh.
Get that little bounce.
- Oh you see the bobble head?
It's that neck snap. Look at this.
- But look at Apollo.
Look at Apollo though.
- You can see the air between the shot
- Bro, but...
- You can't tell me that
boxing in Rocky's real
- Nah, come on, come on,
this scene right here
- That was the best exchange.
- That looked like it's real.
- Apollo threw back. That
was the best... bruh.
- Nah, come on, Rocky been on that ass
Apollo been trying to
keep away with that jab
Bang, bang, snap in that jab,
and he's looking good while he's doing it.
- I like that little clinch fighting
for two seconds.
He hit the ref, dog. He hit the ref.
- That's realistic
- Yeah, you can't be smelling salt.
- You can't do that in the ring though.
- That's a dirty trick
- Yeah that's a dirty
trick you can't do that
- You got my hype man I
wanna get a little bit...
- Yo Kenny, throw a right hand over here.
- Nah, nah, it's not like that.
- It's like that, every
punch in Rocky was like that.
- You been to the fights, Stallone
you in like the hall of fame, baby.
I need to see some more technical boxing
for the new film, alright? Salute though.
The thing is for like the general public
we're boxers so we can notice the little
technical things, for the general public,
a person who's never been in a fight
in their life, street fight or in the ring
otherwise, they don't
know what they're seeing.
They see a punch, land, a head pop,
oh my god it's the best thing ever,
but to a person who's a boxer and you know
the technicalities. It ain't real.